good evening and welcome to Stratford on
aen District Council planning committee
my name is councelor Lewis Adam I'm your
chairman for this evening uh I'm going
to start with some housekeeping uh
there's no fire drill plan for this
evening so if it does go off please uh
evacuate the building and the must point
is the car park adjacent to the pub
across the road
um right so uh this is a meeting in
public not a public meeting which means
only those who are registered to speak
are permitted to do so um at which point
I will call you forward and give you
further instructions can you please make
sure your telephones are off or at least
silent so that they do not disturb the
flow of the
meeting right um oh and the last thing
is uh it is being recorded and broadcast
on the website uh I'll just introduce
our top table from democratic Services
is Cara Keller our solicor this evening
is Sue Mullins our planning manager is
Emily napia and our uh planning officers
are Charlotte dicks Amy flute and uh Joe
Brooke I believe Emily you have a
statement you have
prepared thank you chair my role tonight
is to provide impartial advice to commit
committee members and to assist members
in their decision
taking lovely thank you very much okay
we'll now move on to the agenda proper
uh item one apologies for absence
we have apologies from councilors Curtis
Eden and
Keithley Dary good thank you very much
it was well welcome in uh councelor
passingham as well okay uh item two
disclosures of interest um I'll begin
with that one and just say I've um I was
the previous W member for item four uh
which is
application
oout L west of Jubilee field Stockton uh
and I commented on the application when
I was the ward member as such I'll be
stepping down from the committee um at
that point I've also been contacted uh
by a number of people on that
application as I believe other members
have been so I take it there'll be a
blanket dispensation for them okay uh
councilor Parry
next hello and good evening chair um I
have registered to speak for the final
applic on this evening's agenda
application number
23585 SL full um and therefore as the
ward member will be stepping down from
the
committee sry good thank you very much
any
further uh dispensations no very good uh
item three then minutes uh so we've got
minutes of the meeting held on the 16th
of August uh uh we've all had
opportunity to read them any comments
before they are
approved no happy to agree with them
yeah agreed thank you uh we also have
minutes from 13th of
September uh any further comments on
that no agreed with them them okay jolly
good I'll sign those off in due
course okay um as stated um item number
four then is application
3/ um I will be stepping down from the
um chair for this item um unfortunately
my vice chairs are uh have both had to
send in their apologies this evening in
which case committee has to elect a
chair for this item uh can I have any
proposal please um councelor Holmes
first um propose counselor Harvey for
the position of chair for the item jolly
good thank you very much uh Council
Parry uh delighted to second that
proposal for councelor Harvey to take
Char good thank you very much uh any
further comments from Members no which
case we're going to have to vote on this
one so can I see all those in favor of
casla
Harvey and uh well I don't think we we
cannot have any opposition so I'll take
that as unanimous in which case for this
item uh councelor Harvey will be the
chairman thank you very
much
thank you fellow counselors
um first item is item four
um
application
02330 UT land west of Jubilee Fields
Stockton uh our presenting officer is
Charlotte dicks um we're very much
looking forward to your presentation
with
interest thank you
chair so the site is indicated on the
map by the black circle the application
site is located to the south of the
village of Stockton in the Open Country
Side this slide shows the application
site edged in red it is an open field
which has a Scouts Hut on the Eastern
side of the site where the site meets
the Jubilee field Housing Development to
the
east you can see the rear Gardens of the
houses on St Michael's Cresent to the
north of the site and to the West is a
recreation
field you can also see the nearby public
rights away which are indicated by the
dotted green lines with listed buildings
indicated by the red buildings to the
north of the
site the green circles on and near to
the site indicate individual trees with
tree preservation order
as well as a group TP which is on the
western boundary of the
site so this is an outline application
with all matters reserved except for
Access for Demolition and reciting of
the Scout Hut along with 13 new sou and
custom build dwellings this slide shows
the existing site with the Scout Hut and
Associated hard standing on the Eastern
side of the site you can also see the
existing trees and vegetation along the
boundary of the
site this is the indicative site plan
which shows the developable areas and
plot boundaries for the 13 dwellings on
the southern part of the site with a
drainage basin indicated to the east of
the site and the indicative location for
the Scout Hut to the
north vehicular access for the Scout Hut
would continue to be provided from the
North Via St Michael's
cresant and the housing would be
accessed from juil fields to the
East as shown by the map with the blue
arrow in the corner this photo is taken
from the access from St Michael's
Cresent this would continue to be the
access for the Scout Hut number 2 a St
Michael's Cresent is visible on the
right hand side of the photo with the
existing tree belt on the left hand
side this photo is taken from further up
the same access
point you can see a glimpse of the Scout
H in the rear of the photo with an
ancillary building for two St Michaels
Cresent on the rightand
side this photo is taken as you emerge
from the existing access into the field
itself the Scout H visible on the left
hand side with the side elevation of
number 18 jubile fields on the far
left the southern boundary of the site
is indicated by the trees that you can
see in the
background
this photo is taken from near to the
Scout facing north as indicated by the
blue arrow towards the rear Gardens of
the properties on St Michael's cresant
an elder tree with a TPO can be seen on
the left hand side of the
photo this photo is taken from a similar
location just panning around to show the
western boundary of the site indicated
by the trees that you can see this group
of trees is now the subject of a group
TPO this photo is taken panning around
again looking towards the southern
boundary of the site now the Scout H is
just visible on the left hand side of
the
photo as shown by the arrow this photo
is taken from within the field itself
now Facing East towards the proposed
access for the housing element of the
scheme the Scout Hur is visible in the
foreground with number 18 juile Fields
visible in the background
a protected tree is visible on the right
hand side of the photo with a further
protected Tree on the left hand
side this photo is taken from Jubilee
Fields facing west towards the proposed
access for the housing element of the
site the protected horse chestnut tree
which is T4 which is visible on the left
hand side of the
photo just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet and and officer
recommendation is to refuse the
application based on reasons number one
and two on pages 40 and 41 of the agenda
and the revised reason for refusal on
the update sheet thank you
chair thank you Charlotte um can I draw
members attention to the update sheet
there is quite a lot there
the key points I think are uh the
reference to drainage and the withdrawal
of Reason number four given for refusal
or recommendation for refusal and the
revised wording as on the bottom of page
one and page and top of page two of the
update sheet for the revisal wording for
uh reason number
three on we go then to our first Speaker
of the evening on this
application who is councelor Howard
Collison chair of the Stockton Parish
Council
welcome Council Collison I presume
you've done this before know the form
yes thank you Mr chairman good evening
excellent uh you'll have three minutes
can I give you the option of uh giving
you a warning at 30 seconds before the 3
minutes elapses would you like that or
would you not I I should be okay thank
you Mr chairman well done when you ready
off you go Stockton has a limited range
of housing Styles firstly due to its
history as a cement Village uh when
Nelson's built four roads of terrorist
houses in the late
1800s and then secondly in the last 40
years we have seen four or five identic
Estates from the large National Housing
building companies During the period of
the core strategy there have been only
six or seven that were one-off homes
that were were effectively self-built
where the families bought the land and
built their homes to their own design
there was a distinct lack of variety and
visual appeal in the village this
development will bring a different type
of occupant with their own distinctive
appro approach to house design that will
widen the appearance of the
village During the period of the core
strategy since
2011 The Village was in opposition to
many of the proposed large developments
but now that they're occupied we've come
to realize how easily the new families
have been absorbed into the village
community often of a younger age group
and with young children they have added
to the variety and strength to the
community life of the village
organizations such as the school the
church the pub the working men's club
the football club and numerous Community
groups are stronger as a result so
there's no reason to suspect that
another 13 families will result result
in anything but further diversification
and strengthening of community
life the parish council's response to
the current South warer local plan is to
support further Housing Development as
long as there is some obligation to
provide appreciable benefits to the
community something that's been sadly
lacking in the recent
past the developers of this site also
own the adjacent field to the Northwest
that has been used since the 19 60s as a
children's playing field in accordance
with their grandmother's specific Wishes
the parish council has worked closely
with the Developers for the last 10
years or so over this application on the
understanding that they will grant the
parish council a
999e lease at a pepper corn rent for the
playing field guaranteeing its future
into into perpet
perpetuity the importance of this
security of tenure is demonstr by the
fact that a new enthusiastic Playing
Fields committee has been able to secure
over £40,000 in grant funding to
commence a program of re refurbishment
of the play facilities a long-term lease
will allow more long-term planning and
funding unfortunately like most playing
fields in more more remote locations It
suffers from Petty vandalism of the play
equipment so the parish council hopes
that this new development being So Close
by and with ready access that suchar
vandalism should be
reduced the planners admit that the
issue of self and custom build homes is
not adequately covered by the core
strategy which leaves the interpretation
of planning policy fairly subjective
they also concede a shortfall between
demand and
Supply I am sure that the issues that
the planning officer is raised can be
resolved through suitable
conditions
thank
you yes uh members uh do you have
questions for councelor Collison
please councelor
hen good evening welcome um have you had
a recent housing service needs done uh
yes we had a housing needs survey in
2021 okay um and what was the result of
that was it was it was specifically
aimed at exposing the need for
affordable homes so it wasn't really
aimed towards this sort of
development okay thank you thank
you thank you councelor councelor
Fleming good evening um you were saying
about these are going to be individual
houses you know individual styling we've
learned sort of uh over the last two
years I suppose that when we go for
self-building custom homes on these type
of developments you pick from a catalog
so you're going to have a few of the all
the same on there so they're not going
to be all individually styled in the
same way that the individual plots have
been done in the past so I just wonder
you know have you had seen sight of what
they intend to build you're supporting
the scheme but have you actually seen
sight of what the options will be to to
for the houses well until the individual
designs come forward for each plot we
have no knowledge I mean there is a
design guide that's been a that's been
agreed um and which the parish council
participated with a developer in but it
does leave a lot of of variation and
ability to you know to um put your
individual design in they're they're
certainly not picking off a
checklist uh yes just to comment that
that's a question you might want to
pursue with the agent your first
question um yeah second question then um
looking through the the notes and
whatever here there's no uh s s 106
agreement for these houses so um what uh
you know what we're trying to establish
is what's going back into the local
community if anything at all um and uh
are you supporting on the basis that
there might be stuff coming back into
the into the local community or are you
happy that there's going to be none well
I think we've already got an indication
of um something a fairly significant
things coming into the community they're
already uh indicated they're prepared to
give us a 999 year lease they've also
indicated that they're only going to
collect a peppercorn rent of5 a year so
that's plowing money back into the
community
already thank you counc councelor Perry
thank you chair good evening um I just
would welcome your views um the the
officers report highlights that the
section 106 agreement which would
deliver the public open
space
um has not been secured I just wondered
how that impacted your views on securing
the public open space if there is not if
the section 106 agreement has not been
secured um well I mean that land has
already been secured with I mean
currently we're working on a 21-year
lease um but it's been indicated that
they will grant us a 999 year lease so
that land is secured respective of
section
106 any other
questions I see none thank you cison
thank you very much indeed thank
you we turn next to our second speaker
of the evening who is John Acres
accompanied I think by Mr Timothy
sharles welcome
gentlemen now I presume that Mr Akers is
going to do the talking and Mr sharles
is going to do the answering is that
correct
fine um you've got three minutes um
would you like me to give you a warning
at 30 seconds uh yes please all we'll do
can I just say before you turn the clock
on that we've only just seen this
addendum report um seconds ago so my
presentation would will relate to the
report as written although I have just
read the addendum report I'm sure
members of the committee will take that
into
account when you're ready thank you good
evening my name is John akres I act for
the sharles family who've lived in
Stockton for over 120 years and have
given so much to the Village their
outline application made two years ago
is for 13 self-build plots not currently
available in Stockton and a new Scouts
Hut designed by the scouts to replace
the existing rundown building the family
have agreed to dedicate the adjacent
playing field to the Parish Council on a
long lease we will offer a choice of
housing providing surveillance over the
playing field to combat problems of
antisocial Behavior which concerns both
the parish and the police the family
have work closely with the community
right from the start and we have the
full support of the parish council Ward
C coun and many
locals the report shows that the case
officer agrees that the proposals are
acceptable in principle and has three
times been allocated in the sap secondly
there is a shortfall of self-build plots
in the district which this scheme eases
and thirdly she welcomes the layout
which has evolved to meet the needs of
consules until three weeks ago the case
was targeted for approval by delegated
powers strangely the case officer
changed her mind at the final hurdle
without reference to either the
applicant or myself in my long
experience this is most
unusual her report cites four reasons
for refusal now two three of them have
already been resolved the report is
therefore misleading the delivery of the
Scout Hut is a given indeed if their
local needs housing scheme had been
approved in
2016 the new Scout Hut would be there
now there have been over 30 exchanges
regarding the lack of a section
106 uh with the case officer and I have
them all itemized
here the remaining reason for refusal
landscape is entirely new it's not
linked to any consultation response on
file and has never been discussed with
us points made are either exaggerated or
just plain wrong and are not backed by
any hard evidence the L itchington
example is not comparable and barely
relevant the council's Cas on landscape
would surely fail on appeal we welcome
the draft tpos the scheme does provide a
landscape buffer to the Southwest
there'll be a strengthened native hedge
and tree belt between the site and the
playing field to the Northwest replacing
the scrub and brambles which were
cleared we are also sorry we are already
30 seconds thank you we're already in
the process of drawing a landscape plan
and a content to finish this in consult
ation with a landscape officer to
resolve any lack of clarity but my
client should not be forced to waste
time and money including public money
fighting an appeal or having to reapply
I wrote to your officers last week
seeking a deferral to ask for discussion
in a common sense way but the head of DM
replied to say he was minded to reject
this which is now been confirmed by the
team leader if you refuse an application
you trigger a new phase of conflict
costs and delay this is why I wrote to
you and why I appear now I therefore
respectfully observe urge you to approve
the case with conditions or if not to
defer the application give to give time
to reach an agreed solution thank you
very
much thank you very much Mr Akers
gentlemen ladies do we have questions
councelor
Parry thank you chair good evening mras
hello um I'm just sort sort of
interested in the scenario of your
discussions regarding the section 106
agreement um and the reasons why um you
haven't been able to secure this I would
find that very helpful okay um because
normally in that situation if if if
developers haven't been able to secure a
section 106 they would perhaps withdraw
until they have been able to secure
it when come to committee the case is
either granted or rejected but if it's
granted it's granted subject to the
approval the final approval of a section
106 but normally there's a draft section
106 produced and that's produced by the
council we have um had an undertaking
from the case officer which was made
strangely enough a year ago today at a
meeting in Stockton that the section 106
would be produced and that's the first
item on my schedule ual since then a
year ago we've had no less than 30
exchange emails some of which have gone
uh one way and some of which gone the
other asking for the section 106 in
draft to be produced and our solicitor
has asked no no fewer than five times to
the uh Council solicitor we have all
those emails written on this schedule
which we're very happy to share with you
so as far as we're concerned we're only
too glad to come up with a section 106
and we wish it had been done a year
ago are there other questions from
councelors no Mr sharles you've got off
very light it seems
like well done thank you very much
gentlemen thank you thank
you
our final speaker in relation to this
particular application is councelor
Crump the current Ward member for
Stockton amongst other
places I know you know the ropes
ex-chair of planning committee councelor
Crump um I will press the button give
you five minutes do you want three 30
second one it would be helpful thank you
Mr chair okay on your
marks right thank you very much I've
been the W member of this application
since the May elections I no realize is
a complicated and finally balanced
decision I appreciate that this
application has been going on for some
time now but I do think the report has
been slightly rushed as you can see from
a lengthy upay sheet so it could be
brought to an end obviously I was not
shown as the world member and Mr aers
also stes his disagreement around the
interpretation of the flooding
communication which has now been
rectified as well as the public open
space offset and the
Landscaping I believe some of the
reasons for refusal could have been
conditioned and at least one Highway
issue appears to be the officer's
opinion rather than the highways
personally like the agent of would be
happier if the committee defer this
application until 22nd of November until
these points are clarified and maybe
even they'll have a site visit it will
also give extra time for this section
106 regarding the Scout up to be
finalized one or or another which is
important to the
Village the application has positive
points which I mention shortly but I've
also been asked to raise some points
from local residents in GLE CR and
jubile Fields as well as the scouts who
are now are watching on the V YouTube
increasing numberers substantial I
believe I would also like to state that
whilst I don't always agree uh with
Council I don't always agree with
council ad politically I would endorse
his comments in the report as being fair
and reasonable and still pertinent to
this application they concern
construction management plan Community
use and the protection of the scope
movement in
Stockon the parish council's response to
the current consultation on the sa Roy
local plan is is to support further
Housing Development as long as there is
some obligation to provide appreciable
benefits for the Community something
that's been sadly lacking in recent
developments like most playing fields in
remote locations It suffers from Petty
vialism of the play equipment and the
parish council hopes that this with this
new development so close with ready
access that such vandalism will be
reduced and uh the parish council has
worked closely with the Developers for
the last 10 years or so on the
understanding L will grant to the parish
council 999 year leas at a public cor
rent uh for the plan field guaranteeing
its future imp perpetuity it currently
has a 21-year lease which is making it
difficult to apply for Grants as Grant
providers need a longer
tenure the importance of the security
tenure is demonstrated by the fact that
a new enthusiastic plan committees been
able to secure over 40,000 in grant
funding to can grant sorry commence a
program of refurbishment of play
facilities but with a longer tenure I
believe that can access funding running
into six figures
also in the report the issue of sou and
custom build homes is not adequately
covered by the course strategy which
leaves a lot of interpretation of
planning policy the report also concedes
that there's a shortfall between demand
and
Supply uh my resents in G close and
Jubilee fields are concerned about 3 or
four years construction traffic they
found there the street has 20 vulnerable
people who use the road frequently and
they've got concerns about out there and
they are Keen for cancelers to
understand that 26 additional cars the
impact on the street that will have to
access v g close 26 cars would more than
increase be 100% increase in traffic uh
they also concerned that only two
residents responded who were interested
in The
southw Scouting is one of the few full
inclusive activities available in the
local area and their volunteer leaders
have continued to provide support and
vital social care over since Co pandemic
scouting has offered a route into
rebuilding of competence in a safe space
and a vital component in skating is time
Spain do gaining skills and experience
that are unique to the skating program
with increased evidence that time exide
is enormously beneficial to mental
health and Mal wellbeing there's a
definite need to maintain skate in the
ston Scout UK mission is that scouting
AC actively engages in sports people and
their personal development andow them to
make a positive contribution to society
and the skills they need for school
college Jama uh job interview Etc the
sole interest of the first coats
executive committee in the current plan
application is securing long-term access
to a local Vue 30 seconds but enable
them to the continuation of their indoor
and outdoor activities there's no other
suitable venue stocked in the other
local skates groups are over subscribed
we've covered the flooding there's an
issue regarding landscape keeping um
which I'm not sure uh the agent was
aware about it but um but I believe the
agent has confirmed that they will work
with the uh AB arra Coral officer uh to
work regarding the hedges and also
advice on police resulting to deter drug
use and antisocial behavior that has
been caused by by the the overground
Hedge which is there only this week new
equipment has been vandalized which is
most disappointing native hedging has
been replanted and I ask the committee
to defer this application so more
accurate information is available and
more time for the section 106 to be
ratified thank you for the extra time
councelor
Harvey
yes thank you very much
counselor questions to the
counselor councelor
Fleming in your
uh deliberations you've just given us
you said that there will be um
disruption to the close by houses for
two to three years while this is built
on a recent on a recently completed
scheme um in the district for six houses
it took six years to finish it do you
share any concerns that development of
this size could take a lot longer than
that yeah I was reading that their words
they were the words asked me to read so
um um I
think there's got to be proper
construction management plan to start
off with certainly I sympathize if
things have taken six years uh that is
not on uh and I I believe the developer
would um build them out far more quickly
than that um but I I can't really
comment on whether it's me two or three
years but I can fully sympathized but it
can be managed but it's got to be
managed properly and done L and
potentially enforced as well which is
another
issue thank you other questions cancers
no thank you very much councelor Crump
sir we look forward to the
discussion members questions to the
officers for clarification first hand I
saw was councelor
Parry thank you chairman I think it
would be very helpful to have a little
bit of information and feedback as to
why um um the uh applicant hasn't been
able to secure a section 106 agreement
and what are the issues um and how long
that might likely
take um going forward in the in the
event we were to defer thank you before
I ask either of the officers to comment
on that to respond to that I wonder if
it would be given the the section 106
agreement in this particular case is
particularly important I think it would
be counselors might find it helpful if
our legal officer gave an explanation of
how she sees the process for the
preparation in this particular case of
the 106 agreement um it might ease the
case officers um problems as
well okay thank you chair um with any um
section 106 agreement what you're after
is absolute Precision about who is going
to do what when and any any conditions
or parameters around it um obviously we
we're aware of the the overall intention
on this site which is to secure a
essentially a replacement Scout Hut on
the site that's available for the that
um I don't know the terminology that
Scout group is that the correct
terminology um my understanding from my
um planning lawyer colleague and from
and planning colleagues is that we don't
have sufficient detail of those heads of
terms to actually be able to draft that
section 106
agreement um we need to know who is
going who is going to do what what the
timing is whether it's on commencement
of development whether it's prior to
sale of the first plot whether it's on
occupation of the first plot uh we need
to be able to ensure that that any
replacement building is provided in
advance of the existing building being
um demolished and that it's available um
for uh the foreseeable future for that
Scout group my instructions at the
moment are that we don't have that level
of information that doesn't mean it
can't be provided but we just don't have
it to be able to produce that section
106 agreement in terms of how long a
section 106 agreement takes um grab a
piece of string and stretch it out from
a couple of weits to a couple of years
because it's it's dependent on uh
whether or not there are any mortgages
on the the property who owns the land
whether all of the land is owned by one
person whether they can produce proper
title it depends
on how easy it is to reach agreement on
the detail you might have broad
agreement on the on the the overarching
principles but when it comes to the
detail there can be a lot of back and
forth between the parties until you
agree what it's going to say so they can
be relatively quick they can be
relatively lengthy it just depends on
how far apart the parties start and how
close they can
get thank you I hope members found that
um informative councelor
pimberton uh thank you chair um I've got
two questions and I'm going to come back
to the section 106 first question is
I've
uh I couldn't quite see how the
occupants of the site would access the
playing field immediately adjacent I
couldn't quite see that on the on the
plan can somebody just help me with that
because it would seem as far as I can
see they've got to go out around the
cresant and get round again I just that
was just something that I didn't quite
follow how would they act so you to the
West is the is the the playing field how
did how how is it envisage the occupants
of th of those 13 dwellings could access
cuz it doesn't look as though there's
any Gap in that Landscaping buffer to
the West I just wanted just to clarify
that and then I want to come back to the
106 can I just ask the officer can
I um as the officer whether that is a
matter for the to be considered at this
stage or whether it's uh um for later on
when the second application comes
in so this is an indicative site plan um
so this would be something that could be
considered as part of the the
Landscaping element um at Reserve
matters um based on the information that
we have on this stage there is an
indicative um way through shown if you
can see on the left hand side of the
slide through there it's a bit difficult
to see
um but in terms of the Landscaping
arrangements and the detail that we have
at this stage we don't have sufficient
detail to um show how that would be
achieved and what sort of impact that
would have on the
Landscaping thanks my second question is
for the legal
officer
um my experience of
appeals is that the inspector requires
that at least heads of terms for a
section 106 agreement are in place when
the appeal is heard am I correct in that
assump in in my understanding
they'll certainly want an understanding
of what the heads of terms for a section
106 would be um in the event that they
were minded to Grant permission on
appeal whether or not they want that at
the outset I think is more of a moot
point they quite often want a a
completed section 106 by the time the
appeal hearing
starts
yeah
then I think he's he's fair to say by
the time an appeal starts we've got to
have nailed pretty much a 106
agreement on that basis I'd like to make
a proposal U we haven't got that far yet
uh I suspect yet I'm sure there's more
clarification but at the appropriate
time I'm going to make a
proposal thank you
counselor are there other questions uh
councelor
hom on page 25 of the off on of the
officer's report it says that therefore
give uh the current likely shortfall
between supply and demand significant
weights um how uh have the officers
concluded that that is not sufficient to
override the other concerns that have
been raised um
already we do have to give significant
wi to buil elements The Proposal um on
the other hand we do have to weigh that
up against the loss of an important and
valuable Community facility and balance
that in terms of
um how that would impact on the the
local area in terms of cs25 and the
requirements of that so we have taken
all of that into account in the planning
balance in this case due to the lack of
information to put into a section 106
agreement we've unfortunately had to
recommend refusal for those reasons
because of the resultant loss of that
community facility without the section
106 to secure
it happy councel Tom well done other
questions for the
officers I see oh counter passing um
there there was a housing needs
assessment done but it didn't cover this
kind of housing um because presumably
these are going to be more expensive
housing is there any way of putting a
condition on these houses that makes
some affordable
housing the application has been put
forward for South and custom build
housing so affordable housing is not um
part of their proposal um and as sou and
custom build housing if there was a
section 106 agreement completed to
ensure the provision as section as sou
and custom build housing they would not
be affordable units um as they are very
different in terms of the assessment we
are unable to condition these self and
custom build as affordable housings as
their opposing types of of housing
effectively right
thanks other
questions fine we can turn to the
debate
counselor pton uh because he may um draw
the matter to a head too soon so to
speak are there other people who'd like
to speak before councelor
pton you're on councelor pton thank you
chair
um if the section 106 agreement had
been uh finalized in terms of the
retention of the Scout etc etc this
would be an officer delegated decision
it's got Parish Council support it's got
Ward memb support I understand and do
not criticize officers uh for bringing
the matter forward there isn't um a
section 106 and uh it's not our job as
the committee to rehearse why that is
the position uh and I and I'm sure there
are good and valid reasons why that is
the case having said that uh I do have
an eye to the practicalities and my
question around the appeal um I don't
want us looking down the barrel of a
cost award because we end up agreeing a
section 106 that an inspector will turn
around and say you could have agreed at
some point on on that basis I'm
proposing that this matter be deferred
by this committee to allow further
consideration and agreement of a section
106 uh in the hope that they a scheme
that seems nearly there uh can be got
there through the 106 mechanism uh and
we can also uh do our bit to ensure the
lawyers don't get any richer uh and I'm
seeking a seconder for that thank you
councelor pton uh is there a councelor
who would like to second that proposal
councelor
Perry I would be very pleased to Second
The Proposal um if an application's not
quite right it's not quite right and I
think it's very very important that we
have the section 106 agreement in
place um so that all the little boxes
can be ticked um and then we can all
move forward but it is
inappropriate um to refuse refuse or
Grant this application because I feel we
are missing a piece of the jigsaw so I'd
be great pleasure in seconding councelor
pemberton's proposal to
defer thank you councilor par is there
anybody else who'd like to contribute I
have a proposer in the second councelor
Fleming given the information that we
know now um I was of a mind to agree
with the officer's recommendation to
refuse however SE what my colleagues are
actually proposing um I'll support the
uh the deferment option okay thank you
counselor uh I get the sentiment that uh
councelor Pitt's proposition is well
supported is that the feeling of the
meeting could I have a vote please could
you indicate that
the yeah y I'm going going to make the
point that the uh there are two two
areas where where there is some doubt
one is the 106 and the the other areas
that question of the Landscaping um and
therefore uh when it comes down to the
formalities of of writing down the
reasons for our decision those two
elements will be there uh so those are
the matters to be resolved next time
round that's why we are about to vote on
that basis and chair just to clarify
whilst leading on the section 106 I took
it as read that the second Landscaping
uh element needed to be resolved um we
need to make it explicit rather than
just assume so on that basis uh the the
proposition at this application is
deferred those in favor please show
that's
unanimous thank you gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen uh on that basis
uh
application 21 stroke
02330 stroke UT land west of Jubilee
field Stockton is deferred to a future
meeting thank
you
okay thank you very much councelor
Harvey
um I'm going to shift around the uh
agenda very slightly now um item number
seven which is application
23585 ful Kings me Farm Stratford Road
wellsborne um the reason for referal to
committee is no longer uh Salient and um
we have the opportunity to delegate I'm
proposing that we do so uh do I have any
other views from the
members uh
no yeah so and and that's just to
clarify with Council Parry obviously you
made a declaration on this item that
you're you're happy that uh I was in
support of the application particularly
in view of the history of this
particular site which had had granted
applications on about eight or nine
previous lovely thank you um on that
basis as I say the the reason for
referral to committee is no longer
present so I'm happy to have that one um
delegated to officers
and I think that's all we need to say on
that one um okay so we now move on then
to item number five which is application
627f land off shipston road
ellsmore our presenting officer is Joe
Brooke and when you're ready feel free
to take it away thank you chair uh let
me just set this
up
the application site is located in the
open Countryside approximately 3.2 km
from idle cut and 2.6 km from upper too
as indicated by the black dot before
you this application is for erection of
one agricultural building which would be
cited within the red line boundary
before you so we just complete Clarity
this is the application
site and the building as further
displayed is situated to the front of
this
side it should be noted that this
application follows the approved
agricultural notification for the
proposed track as set out in the
officer's
report the plan before you sets out the
proposed site of the application site
the existing site access track as
permitted in the agnot prior approval
would be utilized for the development
so this is the site of the proposed
agricultural Barn this is the existing
access track which already has plan
permission and the agricultural
application or PR approval this is all
within the offer report so all this hard
standing area is here it is
fundamentally this application for this
agricultural building SED to the front
this is the road running adjacent to the
site if permitted the building would be
a steel portal framed with walls of
green vertical cladding and roof of gray
profile cladding it would be enclosed on
three sides with an open front measuring
3.8 M by 9 M and set at 5.5 m in
height this is an indicative um
illustration of the building the floor
plans as you can see is for bit blurred
unfortunately a four 13.7 me M wide by
9.11 m long I see the indicative drawing
showing the open sided front of the
building and as stated it's 5.5 m in
height this is the site itself so when
coming into the access site this is
facing to the rear uh facing down to the
field so the road is
behind this is the existing access the
agnot track that has already been
permitted under the pr approval which
leads into the adjacent field and also
runs around as you can see by this photo
it runs into the adjacent field this is
not part of the application I should
State this is the road and the Hedge and
fronting the road so this is primary
where the building would be sighted if
permitted and this is the access gate
into the site as you can see the hard
standing there has already been
laid as set out the offic report and in
consideration of the independent rural
Consultants report undertaken by Fox
rule the application is considered the
comply passes as10 and cs22 of the core
strategy however there is a verbal
update at 4m. today WCC highways have
emailed officers prior to committee
asking to review their previous no
objection as submitted on 28th September
2023 officers therefore request to amend
the officer recommendation to Grant
planning permission so subject to
conditions and subject to confirmation
of the highways Authority formal
response on 28th September 23 remains
one as no
objection that's it chair thank you
thanks very much Joe okay we then move
on to our first Speaker who's Martin
Cole um representing uh the parish
council right so uh being informed that
the speaker from the parish council's
ill and not able to speak okay very good
uh sorry to hear that um in which case
we move on to our next speaker who is
Natasha Blackmore the
Sila good evening um so you've got three
minutes um for your submission um happy
to give you a 30 second warning if
you're happy y okay in which case when
you're ready take it away
just a point of clarification I was not
aware of the highways update but I would
accept the condition is part of the
recommendation um good evening I am here
to speak in support of the this revised
scheme for an Agricultural building at
withy Fields Farm I thank officers for
their constructive feedback and
assistance to date and fully endorse
their positive
recommendation furthering on from the
original planning committee in April
where the application was deferred so
that it could be assessed by an
independent agricultural consultant for
an expert opinion Fox role were
instructed by the council to undertake
an assessment of the
proposals through negotiations with the
consultant the scheme has been revised
to remove the second building towards
the top of the field and to reduce the
size of the remaining building as per
the plans you have already seen
following on from these amendments Fox R
has confirmed their support of the
application stating that the amended
proposal is considered to be appropriate
in scale and design and considered
reasonably necessary for a small holding
mixed Enterprise of mostly grassland
with breeding use hay production small
scale poultry and horse culture
therefore this res revise scheme meets a
gening need that has been assessed and
accepted by the agricultur consultant
and the previous reason for deferral has
been dealt with the parish council have
maintained their objection to the
amended scheme on the following grounds
they would like reassurances that the
building is what is required and no
larger it will definitely be used for
the purposes of Agriculture and they
rais concerns that the building in the
future may be used for the purposes of
building a house the agriculture
consultant has confirmed that the
revised scheme is acceptable in terms of
scale need and design and therefore the
first reason for objection has been
dealt with regarding reason two the the
applicant has confirmed that this
building will be used for agriculture to
support their small
holding and as additional reassurance
the officer has suggested a condition
restricting use to solely agriculture be
attached to the decision notice which
the applicant will will happily
accept regarding reason three local
planning policy does not allow for the
conversion of modern agricultural
buildings into dwellings so this
building would be would not be eligible
for conversion under a full planning
application Additionally the class Q
prior approval process only allows
agricultural buildings to be converted
that have been in use for a minimum of
10 years therefore this building would
not be eligible for conversion under
this mechanism either not withstanding
the above the application must be
considered as is and therefore
theoretical future development options
are irrelevant and would need to be
assessed on their own merits against the
relevant planning policy and legislation
at the time class Q may not even exist
in 10 years and we cannot refuse an
application based on a potential future
scenario in summary Fox rural were
consulted as per the committee members
previous request and have confirmed that
revised scheme is appropriate and that
they are supportive of the application
the officer's report also provides a
detailed justification for granting the
application we hope that this is a
straightforward decision to approve the
scheme in line with the case officers
and the agriculture Consultants
recommendations and trust that members
will agree I am happy to answer any
questions you may have thank
you thank you very much uh h on the time
members do we have any questions for our
agent this
evening no nothing from the members in
which case thank you very much for your
contribution all right in which case we
can now move on to our final speaker who
is W member councelor W
hens good evening
counselor very
good uh so as you're aware you got five
minutes I'm happy to give you a 30
second
warning and uh otherwise once you're
ready feel free to take it
away once upon a time someone owned a
very modestly sized piece of poor
quality land in a very rural and
pictures area of Stratford District the
land bordered the cotwell IB and could
clearly seen from various Vistas in the
area it was also a well-used commute for
an older mother called Sarah wh dropping
her baby son off at Nursery it was an
enchanting journey through open
Countryside with asmore a particular
Beauty Spot one day she noticed that a
caravan had been brought onto the site
you all know as taller fields and she
thought to herself aha they're going to
want to build a house there as time went
by she was not surprised to see a barn
erected by the Caravan many years later
the owner of the land and barn applied
for class CQ planning permission to
convert the Redundant never used Barn
into a dwelling and permission was
granted the landowner then sold off the
bit of land with the house permission on
it for the princely sum of £800,000 and
the loan the land owners decided to
divide up the rest of the land they
owned in Elmore even more as the sale of
the land with the class Q conversion had
gone so well an application was made to
build yet another barn on a small P
small pass of land barely 200 yards away
from the original Barn that had been
built permission was granted and the
land with a planning permission for a
band Barn was sold off for another
substantial sum the bar with the
permission granted as seen on these
pictures is huge and totally out of
scale for the plot that it sits on
precisely because two Parcels of land
had got planning permission we have
before us yet another application for
yet another barn on the tiniest Slither
of land imaginable which the owners have
now started to refer to as a farm when
it is in fact a patch of grass unable to
sustain more than 10 sheep in terms of
grazing available grazing has now been
further reduced by the substantial
amount of hardstanding that has now been
put in put down in advance of this
planning application which is clearly
seen in the photographs before you
granting this permission will mean that
there will be three bars of considerable
and outer scale proportions for the
plots of land that they occupy in close
proximity the business plan provided has
no credibility these people are not
Farmers they have a sheep keeping Hobby
and need somewhere to store the vast
array of Road and Earth moving equipment
associated with our main income business
never before have I ever seen
highquality cotwell Stone gravel being
used as a driveway to a barn it is
totally impractical when dealing with
livestock their real motives of This
Barn are barely disguised and they have
been aided and abetted in their desire
to build this barn by previous decisions
made and the spurious and unvalidated
business plan that they have submitted
in an attempt to back up their need for
this barn and its future possible uses I
have already brought the overdevelopment
of this area to the attention of John
careford on the 7th of August I wrote
the peace meal development of this land
into a hamlet must be stopped and
courage needs to be shown in holding the
applicant to account for their plan as
the evidence they are providing does not
stand up against any close
scrutinization I believe that the
council's been taken for fools by all
these applications and their agent it is
vital that the Stratford District
Council now looks at the number of
applications and land ownership in this
area over the last three years to get a
true picture of what is precisely going
on here on the 27th of September I
received a reply from John cord he
States just to update you that we have
raised the issue of the crossroads and
cumulative impacts with County highways
I understand that they are undertaking a
site visit to assess those wider impacts
so I am satisfied that they are taking
the issue seriously we obviously try to
manage case loads to address cumulative
impacts but we are bound by the
application deadlines and time frames in
many ways we are in a fortunate position
that we have three live cases at the
same time as it's brought the issue to
the four just to give you some further
comfort and restate the point in my
earlier email we have an adopted plan
that does seek to restrict development
in unsustainable open Countryside
locations which gives an appropriate
level of protection to places like
asmore I therefore urge this planning
committee to do as Mr careford suggests
and to use the adopted plan to stop this
development along with all the others
that are in the pipeline as it is
unsustainable in this open Countryside
location alsm needs to be protected not
developed and that protection lies with
you County highways and the adopted plan
the purpose of planning is to ensure
that no harm is done harm will continue
to be done if this application is
granted today for yet another barn and
yet another supposed Farm all within
barely 600 yards of each other Elmore is
in very real danger becoming a small
scale industrial
unit after Highway's late in the day
confirmation that do wish to properly
examine the cumulative and accumulative
and serious impacts of developments in
elsmore I urge you to at least defer
this application to give appropriate
gravity to its implications and to allow
all authorities to give the cumulative
effect proper consideration and John
cord's assertions surely need to be
properly adhered to thank
you thank you counselor uh just for the
sake of clarity U the photos that were
provided to go along with your
presentation um have Redline boundaries
and associated with them um I don't
believe that's a site in front of us can
you confirm that please that gives gives
you an idea of the road so you've got a
you've got a Crossroads there so I
didn't have the photographs of that so
you carry on further down it just goes
to show you the scale of some of the
developments that are going on than I
just wanted absolute Clarity that this
wasn't the application site that we were
look red line boundary is not the other
pictures are of that thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our Ward member councelor
pton thank you chair thank you councelor
Wally hoggins I I am I right in my
understanding that uh part of your uh
assertion and concerns is
that the application site is a
subdivision of a larger plot of land in
the ownership of the applicant whereby
there have been uh
bonds and is this an example of another
can I just want because I wasn't quite
I was trying to I wasn't quite sure but
if you can just clarify we know that's
not the applic application site that
we've got before
us but you've mentioned a question of
accumulative impact so are we talking
about a larger piece of land in one
ownership where there have been a number
of bar developments already that if you
could just help me with
that um thank you I wonder um Mr Brooks
if you could pull up the what three
words picture that I managed to pull
there to just show that sort of global
there's a that one there so that gives
you an implication there so can you see
the square box with the three lines in
it there that is more or less that from
that point can you see that if you
chopped at the moment it looks a bit
like a a backwards L shape so their plot
of land there is from there to the top
just there it's not the square bit it's
just that one bit of land there to there
it doesn't include it's not the shape
it's just the the stalk of the L for one
of a better phrase So within that very
small patch of land this will be the
third barn there that's being built so
it was all of that land my own saying
was owned by the same person so as I
spoke to you as I said to you in my
speech Once Upon a Time this was all
owned by the same person and that patch
of land there has just been split up in
order for um development
to to to to happen and has been been has
been sold off for for profit so in fact
you've you've reduced the farming
potential of that if it was the whole
entire piece of land owned that would be
a whole different matter but it isn't
it's a really small piece of land and
you've then got another bit that's sold
off to somebody and another bit and
another bit so my understanding at the
moment is it's one two there are four
different owners of that bit of land
this will be the third barn on this on
this site and that's why the cumulative
effect of this is thank you coun I
believe you you've answered coun P's
question okay thank you uh counc
per thank you chair um so what you're
saying is this large
barn is just for this tiny strip of land
yeah are would we have any evidence that
the applicant owns other land near by
that would would require the servicing
of storage for agricultural purposes do
you want me to answer that
question is that a question for me I I
might haard the that's one for our point
of clarification for our officers yeah
thank you councelor Oly Hollin uh any
further questions for our W
member no in which case thank you very
much
counselor
okay uh we now do now move on to points
of clarification for our officers uh and
I believe counc Perry that that question
uh was pertinent at this
point if I could be um bold could you
repeat the question just so I make sure
that I answer it correctly
obviously the proposal in front of us is
a
large barn on a on a small bounded piece
of
land my question
is the use of that
bom obviously it's a very small Slither
why why would would the applicant need
such a large
Barn if they've only got a small piece
of land it's going to sit on because
doesn't from a
agricultural perspective from
as10 it's to support
agricultural businesses if his business
is only this tiny little strip why would
he need to have such a large
barn I think
the the basis of your question really is
answered in the the principal section of
the report um which is Pages 48 and 49
um obviously this application came
before um committee a number of months
ago in the form of two acultural on and
similar questions were asked committee
chose to defer that in order to um for
for the council to go out to an
independent consultant who would review
it that has been reviewed um it's been
reduced to one that's been reviewed by
the consultant and and they have
considered um and I'll quote um one of
the um the paragraphs from the officer's
report which you can see on page 49 um
the app the the appointed independent
rural consultant Fox Ral considered in
the email dated 19th of September that
the one building as now proposed is
reasonably necessary to meet the
agricultural need of the existing
holding and within that section it also
outlines what what other justification
evidence was submitted in support of the
application does that answer your
question thank you councilor
pton thank you chair
um so uh the County Council
have emailed at about 4M today which is
really helpful I feel for you guys but
am I correct in my understanding that
technically the the County Council 's
position is not now one of support it is
one of it's not one of objection yet but
it's certainly not one of support and
following on from that if the county it
would strike me that if the County
Council highways view does become one of
objection that
becomes that that is a that that would
be fundamental to your assessment of the
application am I correct in that so
there are two things am I correct to the
the status of the objection and if the
uh if the objection were if if the uh
response were to become one of objection
that would be fundamental so if you
could clarify on both of those please of
course
so the the most recent comments that we
have on file from The Count Council were
dated the 28th of September 2023 so
approximately two weeks ago let's say um
we don't know what um the position is in
terms of uh whether they are just
wanting to check um something that has
gone on because I know there has been
quite a bit of Correspondence between
parties in respect of the the Quantum of
applications and recent um a recent
accident in in that area although I do
understand that happened well in advance
of of um the county council's comments
being received previously from my
perspective there is no objection on
file the County Council have not
indicated ated that they are wanting to
withdraw that objection but they do want
to to to review sorry they don't want to
withdraw that no objection but they do
just want to review their comments
that's why the recommendation has been
amended to to subject to that no
objection remaining so obviously in
terms of the officer recommendation if
there was a situation where the highway
Authority changed their comments and
they reconsider considered the position
um that would not be in accordance with
the recommendation so obviously we would
have to consider that um and obviously
we'd have to address that at that time
but if we were still minded to make a
recommendation of Grant we would have to
bring it back if if that no objection
was to change does that make
sense
um there is some there is uncertainty
about the C
position and I again I feel for you guys
but I'm just wondering
why we're actually hearing this now in
the sense of I I am uncomfortable about
uh making a decision subject to a
further consultation I would I I believe
we should have clarity as a committee so
I'm asking the question why have you
just not pull this thing if I know
you've got your official 28th but it is
absolutely clear they want to review
their position and I think for us as
decision makers it does put us in a
difficult position um where it is
absolutely clear clear that the KE key
consulty wants to review their position
um so yeah I would be interested in your
in your clarification around around that
thank
you obviously it's difficult because
we're talking about consult T um but
certainly from what I've got is that the
the officer that made those comments
wasn't in the office today so it may
well be that they just need to check
something with them and they will come
back to them tomorrow but I can't speak
for the highway Authority but obviously
from our perspective like I have said
we've had the highway authorities
comments they have offered a no
objection at this
stage if if they come back if they
review their position and it remains no
objection so their comments are not
altered then um that that's that's the
way the recommendation would be but
obviously if it if they did change their
view um then that wouldn't be in line
with the recommendation and if we were
still minded to recommend Grant it would
have to come
back C hen Sarah hello yeah
um do we know the extent of land that
this applicant has got has he got
further land elsewhere or is it just
this small plot of
land
we don't know because in all honesty for
this application you have to determine
what's before you so the application has
been submitted is as indicated by the
red line so let me just quickly show
that is the red line that's been
submitted and Asus indicate these
ownership are part of is that red line
then you do the policy assessment as
undertaken in the report and Fox's rural
so we can't for this application request
that sort of information so I'd be lying
if I said fundamentally I knew that
answer okay thank
you any further points of clarification
cast
Parry just just a thought um are we able
to
condition the type of materials that
would be stored in the barn that have to
relate
specifically
to agricultural feeds or
hay
um yes in essence but you've got to be
justified in reason why you're doing
that we don't in in my office's opinion
we don't have that justification in
front of us Fox's rules has done an
assessment for the agriculture Holdings
what would be the reasoning for the
tainum you can only store this feed you
can only store this tractors you can
only have that for the attentation
but the but condition for requires it to
be agricultural in use so if they ever
did anything beyond condition for then
technically the it's a change of use
application then it's unlawful
development okay thank you councilor
firing just a quick one um on the basis
of uh Council Hy hoggins uh statement
about what happened previously I know
we're judging this not what we did last
month is giving planning permission for
this likely to affect planning
permission on any nearby applications
that are in at the
moment unfortunately there's no way that
I could answer that question you have to
assess what's before you m yes true
thank you councilor
holes uh one of the issues raised was
the potential for it to become housing
um Can can the officers um reassure us
that under class Q it wouldn't be
possible to to to to convert This
Barn I can't resure you because it would
take 10 years for the legislation to get
in in 10 years time possibly the
legislation may very well change in 10
years but that assessment would have to
be undertaken in 10
years okay any further points of
clarification in which case we can move
to the debate coun
Harvey um I think uh my view is that the
action of the County Council in
throwing a brick in the pool at the last
minute uh puts us in a very difficult
position I I think I'm along with
councellor
pton that the officers seem to be in the
position as things stand their
recommendation is to Grant depending on
what the County Council say they reserve
the right to review that and therefore
we're in a position where today we might
go one way and tomorrow if if the County
Council as a main I mean a very
influential um statutory consult te were
to go the other way uh we would find
ourselves in difficulty so I I don't
think we're in a position to make a
decision on this until we know what the
county council's firm Highway position
is thank you councilor Holmes next um I
think the officers right the officer's
recommendations are incredibly
reasonable and I think we should be
going with that um if if the County
Council does change their position we've
got the ability to to to to to observe
that again I don't think we should let
the conservative County council's
incompetence um stop us from from making
a
decision chairman may I I think you know
pton if you can give me a second uh
Council Holmes I I'll give you a chance
to um be slightly more diplomatic with
your wording I think it's very bold to
suggest incompetence of a of a consulty
not withstanding the late hour of any
any comments that may have uh come from
them so if you might be able to just
comment on on that slightly uh or
withdraw those comments
please I am happy to withdraw those
comments thank you very much councelor
Parry
next thank you chair I'd like to propose
that we defer this application subject
to having received confirmation from the
highways as to their position on this I
think think it is inappropriate for us
to make a decision when the one of the
most essential
consult um is has decided to review
their position perhaps I can have a
second thank
you thank you Council Parry I believe P
councel pton came in
first thank thank you chair I think I've
already
expressed my concern about the position
that that we find ourselves in I take
what the officers say and I understand
technically that's
absolutely right and proper but I think
the Optics of it of coming back to with
a potentially different um
recommendation and I I couch that in a
possibility or no more than that
um does not serve this committee well I
don't think it serves the applicant well
and I don't I think it serves the
residents well um for the want of it
being deferred to probably the next
meeting I would rather us consider this
cleanly with a with a complete
understanding I'm minded that there
clearly has been some question raised
about cumulative
impacts I have no idea none of us have
any idea of why the County Council
officers
and just for for uh the benefit of the
audience it's the officers that produce
the consultation responses um why
they've come to that but they have it is
not wholly
satisfactory but given the late hour
that it comes to but I think we have to
we have to be prepared to be flexible I
do not criticize officers for their view
you know their faced they're between the
rock and a hard place it's 400 p.m. what
are we going to do I do not criticize
them for bring it forward with this as a
as a back stop position and I think it
is you could you could legitimately
argue that's a way forward as a decision
maker I'm uncomfortable with that
strategy we take a different View and on
that basis I am prepared to support and
second councelor parry's uh proposal
that the matter be deferred to allow
Clarity to be secured on the County
Council highways team's view of the
matter so I I will happen second that
thank you councelor pton uh councelor
Harvey you did indicate you wanted to
speak uh I was only going to a second I
probably would have done as I as I
suspected him on both
counts uh
I I I'd like to contribute to the debate
myself as well but um I'm just going to
consult with uh the legal officer very
briefly if you
don't
thank you um members I'm just going to
ask a question um of our legal officer
um this application has come to us now
for a second time uh and the proposal is
to defer on that basis is there a risk
that um appeal could be sought on the
basis of indetermination or
non-determination
rather yes depending on on the time it's
taken for the the application to come
before the committee there is a
potential risk of an appeal being lodged
for non-determination which would
essentially take the decision out of the
committee's
hands thank you um very swiftly
um could you give an indication of the
time scale that we've already seen to
date for uh from the first time we saw
this
application
sorry when you say the first time you
saw the application do you mean the date
of the last committee well as in the
time at which the council was um given
the application and it was made
valid
sorry just have to hold on cuz we have
to open up our Software
System
uh whilst you're doing that Emily um Joe
I might ask one of you as well sorry to
jump back into all most points of
clarification do you mind clarifying the
wording that we received from highways
today in regard to the
um what they were expressing with that
as it were um clearly they didn't redact
or withdraw there no objection so I'd
quite like to have an understanding of
the degree of uncertainty that was
expressed to my knowledge there wasn't
any wording received um there was
correspondence but fundamentally it was
raised to me as being the Pres officer
tonight that there might have been
issues with highways so I sought Clarity
from highways they then contacted
management who then said that we're not
sure because do correct me if I'm wrong
here Emily you can do it
um so as I understand it from from the
correspondence I've had with the the
officers manager is that the officer Who
provided the comments had indicated at
some point they wanted to speak to the
road safety team um but that was before
the the 28th of September comments so
what they are wanting to check I am
presuming but obviously they haven't
explicitly said this is why she wanted
to speak to the road safety team and if
she had before she made those comments
okay um members the reason for my
hesitation is because I wanted some uh
Clarity at the risk that we face in
deferring it I for my part I do share
the um let's say hesitation in terms of
determining this application based on
the information that we have had with
regards to um the input from highways my
concern is that this puts the council in
a vulnerable position with regards to
the potential for an appeal and I want
to be absolutely clear on that risk and
assess it against the risk that seems to
have been rightly raised by yourselves
um with regards to the highways issues
um I'm whilst we're just getting a
further indication on time scale um I
believe councilor Perry wanted to
contribute thank you chair I don't think
it would be unreasonable if if I would
be quite happy having proposed this if
we could say it needed to come back to
the next committee meeting which is in
two weeks time um and hopefully the the
um applicants agent would find that
deferring for two weeks in order to seek
cast on clarification from
highways um would be
acceptable thank you Council Perry
Council pemon uh thank you chair I'm in
agreement with that I'd also observe
that noting that it's a reference to the
road safety team I think actually
reinforces the need to have Clarity it's
that that's a more specific than a gener
generic we want to look at it again so I
think um uh looking at our legal officer
I think it's one I'd be I'd be happy to
back but I've lost more trials than I've
won so you don't want to listen to me
but I think it is road safety I think
that gives us a some clarity there that
there's a fundamentally rational reason
for a deferment to the next meeting
thank you councelor pton um no I I do
agree and as I said I I do share the
hesitation in making the determination
given you know in light of what's
happened today um just check very
briefly on the time scale and then we
can move
forward I I can't um get a hold of the
the date that it was first made valid
but I can see that we sent an
acknowledgement um on the 12th of
January 2023
is um so I would presume it would be at
least received around that date um and
then perhaps validated around them but
but what's happened is because
amendments were received the the valid
date was changed in the system okay
thank you thank you very much and uh for
for the clarification on that
um on that basis as I as I say I I do
share the hesitation I think you're
right that um we do have to make a
decision on all the information um
available and the contribution from the
highways Authority as a material um
statutory consult te is
reasonable um on the basis that we would
look to see this at the next available
planning committee date I'm happy to
support the uh proposal to defer as well
would anyone else like to contribute to
the
debate um with regards the size of the
building um being an agricultural
building and looking at the size of the
land I have
concerns that the scale of this building
is is too big it would only be a small
ho in and um I do have that concern so
uh I'll bring that up at the next
meeting okay yeah thank you very much as
as it does look like um If This Were
deferred we'd hear it again I think
that's perfectly reasonable to raise at
that time are there any further
contributions councelor Harvey just very
quickly it's important that we make the
right decision not a quick decision
and we haven't got all the
information I couldn't agree more uh in
which case uh the proposal is to defer
until the next available committee date
uh made by Council Perry seconded by
councelor pton can I see all those in
favor
please that's unanimous unanimous okay
in which case committee resolves to
defer application
627f
okay uh we have one more application
then which is item six application
6V 192 bambur Road Stratford Upon
aen Our presenting officer is again Joe
Brook and when you're ready feel free to
take it away thank
you thank you
chair
pardon me um we we're about to hear from
the presenting officer um I'll call you
up at the appropriate time for speakers
it's okay thank
you
yeah
thank you chair the application site is
situated on the edge of statford upon
aent at 192 bamry Road as indicated by
the black dot before
you the plan before you shows the
proposed application site it must be
noted that this application is a section
73 variation application from the
already proved
22337 F this is all set out in the
officer's report
that's not two seconds CU that's not
great okay the application proposes that
the extension will project an additional
3 m forward at ground and first floor
level to the front
elevation the proposed single story
extension will project a further 2 m to
the rear than previously approved the
height of the single story rear
extension does not differ and will be
approximately 2.8 M like that of the
existing garage one additional first
floor window on the southern east
elevation is proposed this is will be
obsure Glazed if permitted the
application is also proposed of four
high level ground floor Windows along
the southern eastern boundary these are
block style and also obscure
glazed so for ease and Clarity this is
what's been approved on the left hand
side the four plans so this is the full
application which they have lawful right
to build as is and then this is what is
now being proposed on the right hand
side where I've got the references to
try and help so I'll leave that for a
couple of minutes just so well couple of
seconds no no by all means counselor so
basically these are the four obscure
windows I talked about on the ground
floor window this is the rear elevation
which will project out a further 2
meters than approached I've got the
ground floor plans in a minute as well
uh this is the um so here's the
additional elevation to the first floor
as you can see on that side just make
sure my mouse yeah so you can see on
that side there so that then juts out
additional 3 m and then as you can see
this is the ground floor there that's
proposed in comparison to that one what
has been already approved uh I hope that
helps and by all means I can go back let
me just jump to the floor plans so on
the left hand side of the floor plans as
approved right hand side are the four
plans are proposed what does help with
this is the red uh red elements cuz it
shows what is being proposed in each so
the red is obviously what has been
permitted on the left hand side the red
on the right hand side shows the
extensions coming out as well like the
two meters jutting out you can see the
four windows on the left hand side and
also on the first floor the two windows
proposed on that
elevation this is the actual dwelling
itself situated on boundry road so
that's the front element obviously like
the extensions and stuff will we situate
along
here this is the street scene I have to
highlight it's taken from Google Earth
simply because it gave the best view and
angle it's very hard of our
cameras this is the rear elevations this
is the neighboring properties you can
see and it would wrap round from the
plums I've
shown this then faces to the rear
property to the
left while facing the rear elevation I
should highlight and this is the rear
elevation facing to the
right uh officer recommendation is for
approval as it is indicated the
variation uh proposals would not harm
the existing character of the area or
cause undu harm to neighboring amenities
thank you
chair thanks very much Joe uh okay so
we'll now move on to our first speakers
who are uh Jean Climer and Elizabeth
Dixon
neighbors good evening sorry about the
confusion earlier um so you've got three
minutes between you um it's the button
on the right hand side
to
yeah uh so you've got three minutes
between you um I'm happy to give you a
30 second uh warning yeah I'm doing the
speaking yep okay that's absolutely fine
um when you're ready feel free to take
it away good evening I'm Elizabeth Dixon
speaking for Jean and David Climer who
live at 194 banur road which is next to
the prop proper in this application um a
full application for 192 was granted in
January 2023 increasing the original
footprint of the property by
58% but this variation would increase
the original footprint of 192 by 98%
we're concerned that another variation
could be submitted and increase the size
of the property even further this
variation includes a single story 22 M
extension on the property wall boundary
with four high level Windows overlooking
our home and garden behind the party
wall would be a garage workshop and
study just 135 cm from our property
which would be extremely close to our
ground floor bedrooms where we sleep
we're concerned what might work might be
undertaken in a workshop just 135 cm
away from us it feels rather close and
intrusive this 22 M extension would
extend one meter beyond our front
bedroom and where there would also be an
EV charging point and also 10.8 MERS
beyond the rear of our property Although
our 35-year-old Evergreen hedge at the
rear Garden would partly clam camouflage
this proposed 10.8 M we ask that a
condition is put in place to protect our
hedge throughout on this 22 M extension
there appears to be an unexplained
overhang over our boundary which must
not be permitted this variation also in
includes a 2 m extension completely
across the rear of 1 192 and an
additional
3.5 M deep extension to the front some
of which is two stories high the whole
development is overbearing and having
seen the footprint which is already
marked out it reinforces our belief that
it will have a detrimental effect on our
way of life and on our home if you
visited 192 bamry Road you could see
what I'm saying and I we are ask you to
refuse this
variation thank
you thank you very much uh members do we
have any questions for our neighboring
residents no no questions coming forward
in which case thank you very much for
your contribution this
evening okay uh so our next speaker is
sa
k
good evening uh so you uh you also have
three minutes I'm happy to give you a 30
second warning um and otherwise once
you're ready feel free to take it
away scheme so um in terms of the
comments and the um objections so far in
terms of the front um of the um the
building it's it will go to no more than
one meter in front of number 194 and
that's the um the side uh windows that
we were mentioning are just
for basically for the garage and they
will be completely obscured they are
only on the ground floor so there's no
mitigation to any privacy or any light
to number 194 um also where these four
windows are in question they sit next
next to the um bathroom window of number
194 therefore it's not what we would say
is a habitable room so again there's no
mitigation to privacy there um when
we're looking at the rear extension it
is coming out another 2 MERS if we look
at it within the context of a permitted
development is well within the
parameters of a permitted
development with a rear extension it is
only a single story extension so when it
does come out another two meters there
won't be any windows on the side to
impact either of the
neighbors and it's a completely flat
roof so there won't be any Lantern or
anything like that so the roof is
completely flat again it won't have any
impact to either side of the
neighbors and then the other thing to
mention was yes we did we did put in an
initial application and we we have made
some rather sign significant changes to
the application after having discussed
questions with number 194 because we
wanted to take their um concerns into
account so to that end we have changed
quite a lot of the original
scheme um to ensure
that they're not impacted So to that end
the first floor extension has been
scaled back dramatically so from a first
floor perspective the building will sit
5 meters away from their Bungalow it's
only the ground floor that's coming out
so that has
um as you can appreciate less of an
impact so we bought the property some
time ago about a year and a half ago and
in the we just want to develop it as a
family home and modernize it because it
will be for myself my husband uh to
children who go to school in Stratford
thank you and we are just very keen and
eager to make it a family home and be in
that Community because we have a lot of
friends from school there and um the
children have a lot of friends so we
just Keen to get started make it a home
and we have also looked at a lot of Ecco
credentials for the property um so we're
looking at a build method which uh
reduces carbon emissions by 60% and
solar panels which will help that too
thank you very
much thank you very much uh just just
within your time um members do we have
any questions for our
applicant no uh I do have one very brief
one um obviously you you said that you
had consulted with your neighbors on
this uh and they have raised concerns
about potential overhang um could you
comment on that at all whether that's
the case um when I was looking through
the comments that were made on the
application on the portal I I'm afraid I
wasn't aware of any reference to any
overhang the the concerns that they did
have um I've I'm here to address those
in terms of the um build potentially
being overbearing as they classify it
but I'm I'm certainly not aware of any
specific overhang I'm not sure what that
means I'm afraid sorry okay no thank you
very much uh sorry members any further
questions no in which case thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening okay um we can now move then on
to points of clarification from our
officers
um I'm terribly sorry I'm uh you've been
waiting all evening councelor fradley is
our final speaker
speaker welcome councelor fragile
apologies for that um as I'm sure you
know you've got five minutes very happy
to give you a 30 second
warning um otherwise when you're I think
you've heard most of what I'm going to
say anyway already um when the previous
application uh on the property was
proposed Mr and Mrs climber at 194 were
unhappy with regard to the impact of
their proper on their property a more
suitable proposal was agreed between 192
and 194 resulting in the application
being
granted this current application being a
modification of the granted permission
is putting Mr and Mrs uh climber back
into their original OB objection
the applicant did offer to have a
conversation uh but the date was not
convenient for the climbers since they
were away there has been no further
communication
offered as described the applicant
proposes to build a long wall on the
boundary line which contains four
windows and there's no indication
anywhere about how they're going to be
dealing with the
w the rainwater on this roof um maybe I
suggest that the members of this
committee pay a site visit
um and really we need the the current
version of the application should be
rejected so that the issues between the
two parties could be finally resolved
and agreed thank
you thank you very much um members do we
have any questions for our W
member councel
H oh you say that is built on the
boundary line so you're talking about
overhang for guttering
and yeah but surely that has to be no
further than the boundary line at
all yeah okay I will ask for
clarification
anyway any further questions for our war
member don't believe so in which case
thank you very much councelor
frile
right um as premature before we can now
move on to points of clarification for
our officer coun Harvey thank you um
three points there's a mention made of a
135 cmet Gap could the officer comment
on the significance or otherwise of that
um there's a reference to permitted
development rights and that what's
what's being sought is within the
limitations the parameters of of
permitted development rights um third
question was the councilor um fragile
point about drainage from flat roof
given that the officer has been on site
could you comment on that and finally um
the references to increasing the size of
this property by 58% to
98% uh just calls into the question in
my mind is is there a point at which
this proposal could be considered
overdevelopment could the officer
comment
please
yeah certainly I think some of them are
wrapped up especially probably one and
four uh the reason being is that when
you do your full firstly I should
highlight this isn't green Bel
development so I can give you the Cubit
volume because I've undertaken it but
when the officer went out out to the
site the assessment in this area is the
character of the area plot itself how
the existing neighbors look and
residential and mean it is there's
there's obviously them parking
requirements then G on top but for this
kind of extension given it's already got
full planning permission is the
fundamental element so the assessments
andtake and the plans before you if it
was permitted that's what would be
approved it's been determined that there
is sufficient space between the two
plots based on the character the area
it's been determined that the plot
itself can easily accommodate that sort
of development in the area it wouldn't
look out of out of character it approves
with the landscaping and various things
like that so when you then go onto the
cubic volume to say it's over
development like I said I have to
highlight this is not green belt where
you have to do that sort of assessment
it's been determined that on the basis
of all the dwellings near it and the
character scene and the immunity
standards down behind and as you can see
in Shan's report under 194 banry Road a
very um detailed assessments been taken
on the impact on neighbor it's been
determined that all M elements combined
the plot is sufficient to hold this
dwelling where it comes to permited
development rights I can't 100%
guarantee that because by law you would
have to submit a thing or certificate of
lawfulness and then we would have to
assess the permitted development right
against what's being proposed so if I
sat here right now and I told you yes or
no it would be it wouldn't be accurate I
I I need that certificate of lawfulness
and honesty
drainage it's a building control matter
by rights they have if this was approved
they would have to build it in the court
to some things if an issue came up would
build a control or drainage they'd have
to resubmit the application vary again
and more likely or have to try and find
a way around of it that CA that plans so
fundamentally they have to build in the
C of those proof plans if permitted
obviously I hope that was hard with
them thank you uh councilor Perry
next thank you chair but councelor
Harvey stole my thunder again think he
stole no further question you stole my
thunder as well um councilor
pton uh thank you
um when does a very become a new
application I think is a question uh I'm
I'm we've uh more than significant
expansion at the front and the rear of
this property
um what I'm sure there isn't a defined
line but what are the things you got to
take into account to say whether this is
actually a VAR or we should be
reconsidering it from the ground
up I think it's by means how many you
can ask afterwards because points
clarification you're absolutely right
there is a defined line by case law it
states that it depends on the matters so
if you got an application of a 100
dwellings one application might change
one dwelling would still be within the
remix of the full application
householders is very tricky because in
all honesty the principal development is
already acceptable because it's an
extension so the question being then is
is the impact to such an extent that it
needs a complete new assessment now in
the officer's opinion given the levels
and changes amendments to the
first enough to acire a full but once
again if even was a full the permit the
principle development would still be
acceptable so it would still be
fundamentally assessment on character of
the area landscape residential Mee
highways which has been
undertaken thank you any further points
of
clarification no which case we can move
on to debate who'd like to
start counc
Perry on the basis nobody else wants to
come forward um I'm happy to propose
Grant on this application bamry road is
has a an Eclectic range of very large
properties intermingled with smaller
properties um I'm familiar with many
many properties on a similar size plot
that are much actually much larger than
this um it is within permitted
development rights um the applicant has
looked at the overlooking loss of light
scen scenario um and I can't see a
material planning reason to refuse so
I'm happy to propose thank you
chair thank you councelor Perry if you
two seconds just going to consult with
the
plan
um sorry our planning manager just has a
comment so sorry I just wanted to
clarify one of the questions related to
to the permitted development rights
which you've referred to and I just want
to make clear when when members during
discussion we have not had a lawful
development certificate to to
demonstrate that the extent of the the
alterations to the property would fall
within permitted development rights so
there's no kind of fallback position in
that regard that I would want you to
consider I just wanted to clarify that
because obviously you mentioned
it love you okay thank you very much I
believe councel Holmes going to come in
there yeah I I I'll happily Echo all of
councelor parry's points and seconds
that L thank you very much um any
further contributions to debate Council
passing
um yeah it does seem a rather large
extension for a family home but I can't
see any reason to OB object to it and
I'm quite impressed with the commitment
to reduce carbon emissions by 60% and
solar panels
so thank you very much Council
pattingham uh yeah I mean for my part I
I I do understand the concerns of the
neighbors but I I feel that um our
officers have addressed any any policy
concerns uh therein and uh and found
that they have been satisfied anyone
else want to contribute to the debate um
no in which case we have a proposal uh
and a second to Grant in line with the
officer's recommendations can I see all
those in favor
please that's unanimous that's unanimous
in which case um committee resolves to
Grant application 22
231 336
SLV um okay we just finish off item
eight urgent business Ina in which case
I can close the meeting thank you very
much